every day they have three hour briefings
before a flight where Tom actually is
coordinating and choreographing all the
flights they're going through weather
temperature angles
airplanes knowing what position what we
needed I don't know if there's another
movie star on the planet that could
actually make these aerial sequences
happen he is able to figure out these
sequences like he's actually staging a
battle like he knows the physics he
knows how he wants to shoot it okay guys
let's get to work we're able to get the
best fighter pilots in the world to come
in and do some very special sequences
for us so exciting to watch this and you
see this aerial footage which is
spectacular looking and at such speed it
looks almost unreal and it's real we did
this one Canyon Run and trees were
higher than we were your your canopy is
scraping mountains you're I mean you are
15 feet off the ground you know going to
speed of sound and you're like how the
hell did Tom Cruise convince the studio
to make this movie it's crazy